الصين تخطط لضغط استثمارات بنحو 133 مليار
دولار في صناعه الرقائق الالكترونيه في
خطوه لتحقيق الاكتفاء الذاتي من حزمه
اشباه الموصلات والمواجهه التحركات
الامريكيه تستهدف ابطاء التقدم التكنولوجي
الصينيه وتتضمن خطط بكين اعفاءات ضريبيه
وحزم حوافز لمده خمس سنوات واعانات وقروض
لدعم الابحاث وانتاج اشباه الموصلات
خطه تقييد صناعه اشباه الموصلات في الصين
التي اقرتها الولايات المتحده في اكتوبر
دفعت وزاره التجاره الصينيه لاطلاق النزاع
تجاري في منظمه التجاره العالميه ضدها
موازنه عاليه جدا خصصتها الصين منذ
البدايه تضاهي تلك الامريكيه
فبكين تسعى من اجل رفع حصتها السوقيه
لتبلغ 70 بالمئه بحلول عام 2025 وان كانت
التوقعات لا تمنحها سوى 40 بالمئه كحد
اقصى
ونوهت مجله فرن افيرز انه ينبغي على الصين
انتاج رقائق متقدمه بجيلين او ثلاثه فقط
عن الشركات الرائده في تايوان وكوريا
الجنوبيه لبلوغ هدفها المنشود ما يعني
انها ستحتاج الى ما لا يقل عن خمس الى عشر
سنوات للحاق بركب تطور التكنولوجي فبحسب
خبراء ابرز ما يعيقه تقدم بكين في مجال
صناعه اشباه الموصلات اعتمادها المفرط على
استيراد مستلزمات الانتاج من الموردين
الامريكيين والتايوانيين والكوريين
الجنوبيين واليابانيين الى جانب افتقارها
الى المعرفه اللازمه اذ لا تزال تعتمد على
المواهب الاجنبيه في المسائل التقنيه
مجابهه الفتحاتها الولايات المتحده بوجه
الصين منذ عهد الرئيس السابق دونالد ترامب
ليطفوا على سطح المحيط الهادئ صراع جديد
طرفه الاول تحالف امريكي اسيوي مع كوريا
الجنوبيه وتايوان واليابان لاقصاء الصين
من مستلزمات الانتاج لصناعه الرقائق اما
طرفه الثاني الصين وشركات التكنولوجيا
المحليه